now because the way the scottish
elections work as we were discussing
uh where voters have got two votes it's
possible that alba does more damage to
the greens or even the conservatives and
labor than the snp
now the conservatives are so worried
about this their leader in scotland
douglas ross yesterday called for fellow
unionist parties to put aside their
differences
and form an alliance to stop a second
independence referendum douglas ross
joins us now and
firstly just your reaction to the kenny
mccaskill
interview he says this is all about
helping the snp building a super
majority do you think it will work that
way
well that's what it's all about for the
snp nationalists
i listened to every word from the alba
party representing
kenya mccaskill there and not once did
he mention covered recovery
or rebuilding up this pandemic
he didn't need to be fair well he didn't
speak about
recovery after this pandemic and how we
get scotland back up and running after
the last 12 months because for
nationalists
it's all about another independence
referendum and that's what i was saying
to
fellow unionist leaders here in scotland
yesterday we can't help the recovery we
can't rebuild scotland
when all the narrative from the scottish
government from the snp
and from the alba party it's going to be
focused on another independence
referendum so we've got to work together
to stop them
i'm interested in this you say you want
to work together with other
pro-unionists
and parties you've written to the labour
and the lib dem leaders
have they replied yet yes i mean sadly
they both turned down that offer but
the offer remains we've got to look at
how we approach this new threat
as you said in your introduction there
this is
could split the sm people but they don't
get many msps off the regional list so
it's more likely
to do more harm to the unionist party so
we've got to understand that threat
not ignore it and assume that we can
continue as normal
we've got to put our party politics to
one side in this important reference
effective referendum because the
nationalists want this election to be
about another
independence representative to separate
scotland from the rest of the uk
i'm just trying to work out what this
offer actually means
you know you want to work together with
other pro-unionist parties i mean are
you actually saying that you might go
into government a coalition government
if you like with labor
well that's one of the pledges that we
would sign up to a unionist manifesto if
the numbers work after the election to
work together
to get rid of the nationalists so you
would go into government with labour
i'm saying that's what we need to get
around the table and discuss because
after the last 14 years in scotland
for the snp have been in charge we've
not had the focus
on the economy on protecting jobs on
education and supporting nhs
we've had a focus on independence that's
the snp's priority
and the nationalist priority so we've
got to look at how we can build up
as big a coalition as possible to stop
that and
the speed at which the labour party and
the liberal democrats refused that offer
yesterday
tells me that we've got to just unite
behind the strongest opposition of the s
p then that's the scottish conservatives
i'm a bit confused because you say that
the problem with the snp
and the album party is that they want to
make the selection all about independent
independence rather than other issues
but surely by talking about and and
calling for
a pro-union alliance that is also making
the election all about independence
isn't it
well that's responding to the threat
that has now emerged that the alba party
have set up to work
with the scottish national party to get
super majority for independence
that means there will not be an
opportunity to discuss our recovery
not be an opportunity for the scottish
parliament to be laser focused on
rebuilding
after grouping because the nationalists
will drag us back to the same old
divisive destructive arguments of the
past
isn't the truth that actually making
this election all about independence
benefits the scottish conservatives
doesn't it you want to position yourself
as the most strongly pro-union party
we are the strongest pro union party in
scotland we've shown that
in the last election five years ago we
stopped the snp getting a majority
the scottish labour party so you want it
to be about independence don't you
no i want it to be about education in
scotland i wanted to be about protecting
jobs in scotland i wanted
to be about our recovery from this
pandemic as you heard from kenny
mccaskill
not a single word about recovery or
rebuilding from the alba party
for nationalists is all about
independence so you and you think you
can
choose or achieve all of those domestic
objectives most easily in coalition with
labour
well we've got to work with all parties
who want to stop the nationalists
they've been in power for a decade and a
half and look at what they've done in
scotland
nicholas sturgeon said judge her on her
number one priority
which would be education but of course
everyone can see her number one priority
has always been another independence
referendum and separating scotland from
the rest of the uk
we've got to wake up to this threat we
cannot continue to bury our heads in the
sun like the scottish labour party want
to do the threat is real
it's in front of us now let's place that
break and work together to stop the
nationalists otherwise scottish politics
will again be dominated by the
independence debate
if the next scottish parliament contains
the majority even a super majority for
independence will boris johnson just
refuse to grant a referendum in any
circumstances
well sadly that doesn't even matter to
the nationalists because they've said
they'll go ahead with a wildcat illegal
referendum enemy
so no matter what happens if you vote
for a nationalist party
get nicholas sturgeon's nationalists or
alex salmon's nationalist
their priority will be another
referendum whether it's a legal
referendum or an
illegal wildcat referendum they will not
be focused on recovery
they cannot be focused on rebuilding
scotland when they're trying to rip us
out of the united kingdom
the question i asked wasn't about what
the s p will do though is about what the
conservatives will do since you are you
know the leader of the scottish
conservatives
if there is a majority for independence
in the next scottish parliament
will boris johnson refuse to grant a
referendum
but that's the problem sophie that's
exactly the point i'm making it doesn't
matter
if it will or not though other people
can decide whether it matters people
want to know what it's going to do
yeah and the prime minister has been
clear he does not want another
independent referendum in scotland we
are in the middle of a pandemic we need
to focus on our recovery and rebuilding
but the nationalists will ignore that
the nationalists have already said and
nicolas sturgeon
set up a commission within the snp with
an 11-point plan
to have another independence referendum
even if it's an illegal
wildcat referendum without a section 30
order from the uk government
we know that boris johnson doesn't want
another referendum but will he refuse to
grant
another referendum in all circumstances
the prime minister has been clear he's
not going to grant
him the powers for another independence
referendum because he thinks it's
absolutely wrong for scotland right now
to be dragged back into that destructive
arguments of the past
to go through all the pain and suffering
that we had in scotland through that
last debate
we should be focused on recovery and
rebuilding but the nationals are going
to ignore that and they're going to say
we'll have a referendum anyway and that
will take scotland backwards rather than
focusing on our recovery
and rebuilding from this pandemic would
it be democratic though for boris
johnson to refuse to grant a referendum
if there is a majority
in favour of independence parties well
it wouldn't be democratic for the
nationalists to go ahead with a wildcat
legal referendum but they're going to do
it anyway
and this is the whole point this is why
i'm asking people to unite behind the
strongest party
to stop the snp and stop the
nationalists i'd like to do it with the
scottish labour party and the local
democrats
but if they're not up for that fight if
they can't see the threat in front of us
right now
and people have to see there is a party
that's willing to challenge the snp
willing to stand up to the nationalist
threat that we are facing here in
scotland
and that's the scottish conservatives we
stopped from five years ago we can do it
again
but the threat is very real it's in
front of us now we've got a short time
to stop them
and everyone has to back the strongest
party to stop the naturalist and that's
the scottish conservatives
okay thank you very much for being on
the program douglas ross thank you